So, now that the article is complete,
it's now asking me whether or not we
should push this. So, we see here we see
the URL, we see the document. This will
publish the completed article to the
WordPress site. In today's video, I'll
be showing you how to supercharge your
content writing with ChatGPT and the MCP
connection from Word Rocket. So, in
order to get started or if you want to
get more information about our MCP, head
over to our documents and then head over
to the MCP server integration. This is
where you're going to see the setup
guide. So, option number one is going to
be the easiest for most applications
including ChatGPT. So, first what we're
going to do is we're going to copy over
this URL. We're going to head back over
to ChatGPT. We're going to go into our
profile, go into settings.
We're going to head over to apps. Now,
apps is essentially the same thing as
MCP integration. So, apps is just what
it's called on ChatGPT. So, ChatGPT's
going to have a bunch of different apps
in which you can set up, but we need to
set up a custom application. To To do
this, we first need to go to advanced
settings and we need to turn on
developer mode. Developer mode, as you
can see here, allows us to now create an
app. Right? So, remember, if you don't
see create an app, turn on developer
mode in your advanced settings. Then,
I'm going to go to create app. I'm going
to give it a name, Word Rocket API or
Word Rocket AI. Then, I need to just
paste in the URL that I got from the
setup guide. Just paste that in.
Make sure all authorization is on. So,
that means it's going to be a one-click
authorization, super easy to connect
over to your Word Rocket account, just
ensuring you're on the right plan, which
is an agency plan or a premium monthly
plan. Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just click that I understand I
don't want to continue because OpenAI
hasn't reviewed this specific MCP
server, but we have and we know that it
works completely fine. I'm going to
click create.
Right? Give it a couple of seconds here.
It's going to take me over to my
WordRocket
um application. I'm going to click
approve.
And there we go. WordRocket is now
connected over
uh to your ChatGPT. So, you can actually
allow it to reference memories in chat.
You can turn that on or off. I can see
the actions in which we can do. So,
these are all the actions in which you
can do within WordRocket. We can delete
articles, we can generate articles, we
can generate bulk articles, we can get
the job status, improve articles, list
our brand voices, publish to goals,
publish to WordPress, and research
keywords. So, essentially, anything that
you can do on
WordRocket, you can now do it on
ChatGPT.
Very, very powerful stuff. So, where
does this leave you? Now, this opens up
a whole new possibilities of what can be
done on ChatGPT. You can tell ChatGPT to
do competitive research, to find topics
that are trending in your niche, and
then send it over to WordRocket. You can
upload your documentation from your
companies' drives, things of that
nature, connect it with other apps, and
now have that all of that information in
ChatGPT, and then send that information
over to WordRocket. So, for example,
I've told ChatGPT that I want you to
search up my site, and I've given it my
site URL, do research on the best
trending topic I can write on to get
lots of new traffic, then I want you to
search up more information, send me over
a custom outline in my additional
instructions over to WordRocket. And
I've told it to include web um web mode,
so it researches the web, include
images, include our site map, include
our brand voice, and also post directly
over to our website. Okay, so we can see
we can see the process of Chat GPT here.
We can see that it's went ahead it's
found the topic. It's called the tool so
we can see it's calling Word Rocket to
do keyword research to generate the
article to get the job status.
And once the job is completed, it'll
then post the article directly over to
Word Rocket. So sorry, directly over to
our website. So I just want to log in to
Word Rocket here to ensure that that
article has actually been pushed. So we
can see here that article has been
pushed.
Uh Toronto to Niagara Falls day trip
itinerary 2026. So that article we know
is being
generated through the actual integration
with Word Rocket and not by Chat GPT
only.
Ensuring the content is correct before
publishing. So I like that it's actually
asking us to do this because, you know,
it's telling us whether or not the
article is ready to be pushed. So I like
that it actually asked us and now I've
told it yes. So let's see if it actually
was able to push directly over to that
site. Okay, so the published post is now
on the site. The topic was chosen. Why
this topic? We see the word Word Rocket
setup that was used. Now let's go ahead
and click onto this link. This is always
my favorite part of this process. So we
see here, if we go in, we see that the
full article has been posted with a
beautiful beautiful cover image of
Niagara Falls. Key takeaways, quick
answer,
2026 trip, first stop, what to expect,
guided tours.
If I scroll down, I see the FAQs.
And I see the title, meta description.
Right? So this is a really really well
well-done article. If I go over to my
Word Rocket site again, I can see the
full article here. So here is the full
article that we got back from the actual
um from the actual article in Word
Rocket. But we see that this article was
posted over directly over to our site
using
our ChatGPT and WordRocket integration.
So, hope that you guys enjoyed this
video. As you can see, it opens up a
whole bunch of new possibilities. If you
want to get access to MCP, you need to
be on a plan that provisions it. If you
have any questions, hit me up at
support@wordrocket.ai
or leave a comment below. I'll see you
in the next one. Take care.